in support of small businesses today's
episode is brought to you by charlotte
counseling and wellness now I don't know
if you ever been a Charlotte but I have
and I'll actually be there this weekend
performing but but people there need
counseling and wellness just like they
need it everywhere else the team at
Charlotte counseling and wellness is
staffed with licensed professional
counselors and a licensed clinical
psychologist they're available for
in-person counseling and therapy in
Charlotte North Carolina their
counselors are ready to help you find
calm again go to WWll counseling and
wellness comm slash Theo to get started
today
[Music]
[Applause]
you think that's scary
is that scary music let's see if we have
something scary
[Music]
that's not like some ghosts or uh you
know that sound like maybe a couple of
ghosts sir
like their parents are out of town and
they're throwing a party you know
[Music]
that's what that sounds like let's hear
another scary scary sound
[Music]
that sounds a little bit like maybe like
two swans were like you know have it had
a couple of children one of us loved
maybe like you know they can't find one
of the babies or something kind of
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
yeah that's two that sound like a couple
yeah like maybe some very rich swans
like or out of a lake and one of them
dropped their like cellphone in the
water you know that's what that sounds
like
[Music]
Oh Roger how will I ever find all my
friends on on insta gose what's up guys
welcome to this past weekend thank you
guys for being here I'm just thinking
about how spooky it's getting in the
world because it's Halloween time you
know it's Halloween man Halloween I mean
I used to love do you remember hallouwe
remember the remember how much fun do
you remember remember how much fun you
had remember how much fun you had
Halloween what are you gonna be what are
you gonna be for like a couple of weeks
when you were in like elementary school
middle school what are you gonna be what
are you gonna be I'm gonna be a princess
I'm gonna be a coal miner I'm gonna be a
firefighter that was always a big one
I'm gonna be a firefighter you know and
it was just like a and and the costume
used to be way more normal weight like
Oh Daniel is a bat oh that's good job
Daniel you know Lawrence is um he's a
coal miner in a wheelchair oh good job
Lawrence Celina is pregnant uh oh that's
interesting but way to go Celina you
know you just you see that little girl
she come to the door she you know she
does that's her idea of a what of
creativity she's seven years old she got
a pillow in her you know and lipstick on
you like okay she's you know maybe
seeing a little too much at the house
you know but that was that was that was
then that was that was Halloween dude
and then I remember you would get the
candy and I always liked them Snickers
them baby Snickers you know out here and
and and Los Angeles they give all you
know the costumes are
out here it's not even a it's not even
no you know it's like Jackson is a
hashtag
Lorenzo well he refuses to dress up this
year because he believes that Halloween
is you know it's it's not fair to ghosts
like actual ghosts aren't getting the
credit they deserve yeah well [ __ ] that
bruh Halloween is a great opportunity to
get an empty bag or anything empty did I
remember one time running around our
neighborhood with a plant pot because it
just seemed like the biggest thing
around fill it up
I didn't care what you put in it dude
armor one got us poured half of a beer
out in the mine I'm like here dude I
love getting them little Snickers and I
love putting on my costume you look I
found these sounds remember listen to
these Halloween masks sounds okay these
were sounds that your masks made maybe
when you put the mask on alright here we
go
[Applause]
remember that okay now what about this
one listen to this one that now if you
had some money that second when you had
a little bit of money because they had
that hard that plastic it it was like
getting back in your mother's womb just
once you got whatever that and that
thing was always like a wolf or like a
you know a donkey head or uh you know it
could be anything it would be eating but
it was something like severe like a big
lizard head if you got into that thing
you weren't
hmm that was it for the night I didn't
like those things because I always felt
trapped you know I remember one time
being in a costume and I couldn't get
that thing off man and I could see out
of the eyes and I could see the world
like so clearly but no one could hear me
because the plastic was too thick so I
quit talking to people and it was sweaty
and it was scary because I couldn't like
my peripheral vision was gone so I
couldn't see around me that good and I
could just see and it was just like I
was watching the world happen a little
bit more and I thought for a second when
I honest I thought that was like I
wonder if this is what it feels like to
have like autism or Down syndrome you
know like you're in there and you can
see like it all seems really really
clear but you're like sweating and and
uh and you and you can't and people
can't hear you or you can't like
communicate as well because you know you
got on these you know you got so much
extra on you you know mm at that getting
into that one this is another one isn't
one more sound here we go that's kind of
similar similar one but yeah Halloween
oh man Halloween and you were run by you
have that candy dude I remember this one
it can be so bad I remember grabbing
like my wiener and just squeezing it
that's how bad and I wanted that snicker
man every time I wanted that snicker
that's exactly give me this or did they
have the snicker no somebody had a
sucker what is dad [ __ ] I'll get that
at the bank
I'll get that at a bang at a at a bank
I'll get that at a Whitney bank that's
what they used to have in Louisiana that
Whitney Bank
it's crazy man
it was so much fun dude and I remember
my mom had that station wagon and the
station wagon do you could hide in the
old school now they got these little
Subaru Legacy you know we had that we
had the station wagon this thing was
that war war to hit her I'm saying if
you got far enough into the back you
could hear soldiers fighting that [ __ ]
the fifth row you know the they had the
backseat then they had this big
extra-long area that was straight up
Dunkirk back there people were losing
their lives back there and my mom they
had the station wagon had an arm it had
a thing it dropped down you know cuz
this is when I was this is when I was
probably let me think
five okay or six and they had that that
the station wagon had a back thing it
was a like a tailgate it was a tailgate
and we'd just drive down it was heavy
bro if it came down you you didn't put
it back up till maybe spring time or
until a different time of year you know
it was that thing was heavy and we would
all get on there and hang we would all
get up we'd stand on there and be all
dressed up in our costumes you know
everybody would be keyed up and just you
know somebody would be a um somebody
would just be like I'm a I'm a like a
bloody ghost and they would just you
know have blood all over him and maybe
have a bed she kind of tied around them
they actually just looked like a Greek
person that had been you know in a
domestic dispute you know you'd have
some horrible [ __ ] costumes you know
now it's a little bit more like the
parents dress the kids I feel like when
I when I was young you drew dude I'm you
just you know I remember you put a
little bit of dirt on you like ah on my
um piece of sod you know you put a
little bit of suck you know maybe some
grass in your hair but it was fun man
we'd all get on the back of that we get
on the back of mom station wagon and
she'd let us stand on the tailgate she
let us stand on the tailgate cuz I lived
in America in the
90s and you could stand on the tailgate
and you could hold on to the top of the
station wagon and mom would drive around
the rich people's neighborhood and I'd
be on the back out ad man just waiting
you see a house where it looked like
they had somebody sitting out front like
a senior citizen or something you know
in a rocking chair and they were all
dressed up and they you know they had
like uh maybe some decorations like all
these mother has got that snicker these
the people that got the snicker because
when I was young that's all you wanted
man
some people during Halloween they were
giving out the little they used to have
these black these candies they were like
it was just a it was kind of like
somebody at they were orange and black
the it was just wrapped up and it was
barely wrapped up some of the candy was
kind of leaking out the back end you
know some of the candy had a little bit
of side boob kind of you know a little
Brown kind of side boob popping out it
uh the wrapping you know these little
candies they came in little wrappers
little you know little blankets little
duffle bags for candies were you know
wrappers wrappers and and that would
give you these into his Chewie it was
chunk you didn't even it was it was unn
it was the unknown candy it was like the
tomb of the unknown diabetes it was just
us chunk of you were like oh is this
chocolate is it caramel and them is an
apple and you would just eat it and by
the time you even kind of maybe had an
idea what it was it was gone and you had
no idea what it was and it was actually
absolutely just nothing just garbage
straight up just that I mean it was I
mean it could have been a polio vaccine
I have no clue what it was I mean it
could have been I just remember it got
you sugar up and got you amped up to go
another couple blocks you know and I
remember a couple of them if you had two
or three to orange ones in a row you
couldn't turn your neck for a little bit
that [ __ ] would get my neck all tight
make my veins really start you know make
my veins kind of dance together and kind
of get to know each other a little bit
maybe even doing you know make it make
you feel like it
didn't want it your neck would get tight
if I had too many of them little because
they were just unknown candies they
didn't have a name to him they were
cheap and they just it was just enough
to get you to that next house and see if
they had a little thing of Smarties bra
rich people always had Smarties or you
know it love Snickers no you on
Halloween bruh
dude I would train all month in October
at the house stretching you know
fighting my getting beat up by my
brother you know pissing my mom off let
her hit me with that leather because I
was gonna be ready for October 31st when
Daddy little daddy hit the night time I
thought I was about to rock we salute Oh
hit the night time going looking for
that snicker and they call me and they
see me they see me and they know I'm
hunting that son eka and I'd be out
there and we'd be on the back of moms
and I've told this story yeah I probably
told her last I only not be on the back
we'd all be lined up on the back of us
one of us you know somebody's just easy
easy easy costumes somebody's a turtle
you know little Ronald's a turtle you
know little Fanueil he's a um he's a
goat and he gots real goat hair his dad
put real honey and goat hair on his back
to make him look out authentic and he's
a real little goat boy and they put
little fake horns on his head you know
and they squeezed him maybe into a um
they might have squeezed him into a mask
I don't even know they might have
squeezed him in one of those tight
hitters and little fan yells all keyed
up and maybe they even maybe his dad he
had a little bit extra time off of work
you're in October and he put real wood
on the bottom of his shoes and he any
any and he nailed it into the bottom of
his shoes or super glued it onto the
bottom and painted it black so now
little Daniel got real hoofs and he you
know maybe he's out there in the oven um
you know children's underwears or you
know or even sometimes in Halloween you
put on a baby diaper he'd put a diaper
on your body you know in case you
wanted a piss or something because you
wouldn't you know we went hard at
Halloween there was it and we was in we
were on enemy territory we're out there
trick-or-treating by the ridge
do you trick-or-treat in my neighborhood
do you get probably you get a rash for
sure bedbugs you get probably I mean say
they have registered a lot of registered
sex offenders by us so you know none of
these freelance boys I'm talking people
in the Union you know them real hitters
so you wouldn't really you know a lot of
people buys then you have calendars you
stop by dressed up you know they might
think you a real animal if you come by
little Fanueil rolls up as a goat
brother they might [ __ ] grill that
boy up
you know we having a little bit of we
having some rack of Fanueil back here
next weekend we having a barbecue but
yeah man we would go and Daniel would
have heat up maybe real goat hair on him
you know his dad would put honey on the
back of his legs and honey on his back
and then they had real goats so they get
real hair off these goats because that's
free if you have goats that hair is
yours if they're cool with it and you
put it on any like damn that boy looks
[ __ ] he's a real swaggy piece out
here and we'd all be on the back of the
and we'd have those diapers on because
we weren't going back home you know I'm
saying if you if the diaper was because
if you wanted a urinator
or you know or make duty and you could
do it right there and still
trick-or-treat because this was our this
was our Vietnam October 31st it was us
against the world
it was us against these candy makers in
these people would have had front doors
and these people that had
jack-o'-lanterns and it was us and we
was going to get ours we were going to
get them but then baby snicker and man
it was epic and we'd all be on the back
of that [ __ ] on the back of mom's car
with that with that uh with the tailgate
down and she's rolling bro she's
cruising because she's pissed because my
mother was always pissed
think about a time when my mother has
been alive she was pissed then I promise
you and we're on the back of mom would
roll up by the yard and we would run and
jump off that tailgate into the yard as
that car was going just like I have to
right up the back of a c-130 man shout
out to all of our servicemen and women
just just right out in the yard and
tumble roll into the yard lose half your
[ __ ] candy in the roll what-whatever
onward onward hold the line forward I
would roll out onto the ground you know
your brother your anything your sister
would come off at the last minute she
only 2 years old
in the [ __ ] and that that mom car
still rolling just coming to a stop and
my sister just fought all off that [ __ ]
she couldn't even jump her legs didn't
have that jump ability in them yet they
was just you know just them [ __ ]
little pushers she would just kind of
push herself and then just fall and she
fall right off the tailgate and
whoever's yard it was some rich person's
yard and then it was just every step you
could get through the dark grass to get
up to that front door and you would just
ring that damn Bell you would knock dude
I would ring and then knock and if they
weren't there within half of a second
I would ring again and you would fight
over who got to say Trick or Treat
remember that cut rolling up close to
the door eat of it you'd have a six
minute fist fight over who gets to say
Trick or Treat and then you get there
and you but and then they open it up and
sometimes inside you see people having
fun families you know remember they're
watching TV or tickling each other maybe
the dad if he's rich he might be
throwing a piece of popcorn up in there
catching in his mouth you know maybe the
kid you see you got a nice pair of [ __ ]
you know extra shoes or cleats by the
door whatever they got calendars you
know legitimate calendars from the
siddhis from
actual year it was on the wall and then
and the mom is right there and she got
the big bowl and she's dressed up like a
little cat or like a uh you know a
female lemur or something's kind of sexy
you know like a little deer and they she
got that bowl and man you hope that
snicker was in there god I'm I loved
Halloween and then it was on to the next
one and you make the street and then you
there weren't as many you know you
didn't see as many porch lights on you
be like alright let's get back on the
car let's get back on mom's tailgate go
mom
and mom's complaint is everybody who
gives a cow oh you're back a yelling bra
half your candy you don't you know you
point you getting your brother to look
at something stealing after his [ __ ] you
got all the candy bags tied around your
sister's neck she's at this point she's
just a sugar mule she's just mewling
sweets all right yes you know she's 2
years old building up thighs she you
know by that by the end of Halloween
night by November 1st she got thighs
look like a damn quarter horse look like
a uh pony that was raised in quicksand
and it's still alive she got them big
strong thighs and she just got 9 bags of
candy tied around her and she just mule
and sugar and you guys back on the
tailgate again you're going and you see
another person's yard and we'd run and
we jump off and I never forget what
happened man little Fanueil jumped off
in some people every now and then some
some real [ __ ] rue has to have a
hydrant in the front of their yard and
you know what's great about them they
don't put lights around the hydrant they
don't put any it's just a hydrant in the
front of the yard and this person had
painted their hydrant brown so it would
match their house what a real Albert
[ __ ] Stein so
we all runnin off we jump into the yard
1 2 3 just parachuting off the back of
mom's tailgate and a little Daniel a
little Daniel that little goat boy you
know he's all shook up he's hopped up
he's having me about [ __ ] 65 rolls of
Smarties and 15 of those you know
unidentifiable brown and black candies
he got so money he and those things you
could even get him it just gets stuck in
your teeth remember that remember those
Canton that's all they were those things
is the orange and black would they just
get all it was was something that kind
of tasted like coffee and we get stuck
in your teeth come on but a little
Daniel Bryan it jumped off and in the
dark he thought it was yard because we'd
all hit yard and Daniel [ __ ] just
just landed right into that a fire
hydrant just I just imagine flying
through the air Halloween on your brain
65 rolls of Smarties in your system
hopped up I won't be able to close your
eyes for a month you got so much glucose
rolling through you you got real honey
hooked goat hair on your back your daddy
made you [ __ ] wooden hooves you got
pine who's nailed it into the bottom of
your Reeboks and you got on a diaper
full of urine and possibly number two
pens are now fired up you were and you
got a [ __ ] damn goat mask on your
face and out of nowhere just out of the
pitch-black a fire hydrant you jump off
of a tailgate in enough pure darkness
and you hit a fire hydrant hmm and then
boy was never the same never the same so
but that's Halloween man
god I love it and I miss it and I'm
happy to be here man crazy but different
back in the day people you could dress
up as an apple you know an Indian we
have way they had a black kid came our
door as an indentured servant like
whatever people didn't care if it wasn't
like oh this means this this mean
whatever this is a kid they want to
dress up let him dress up you know I you
know I I people know I've been
peppermint pattie for and I'll get a you
know what cotton you know some cotton
body cover and stuff and you know shirts
and that and pants and I put little
peppermints all over them
and people are like who are you and I'm
like I'm peppermint Pat and they're like
who is that and I'm like who it's no one
it's peppermint pat you know I'm saying
I'm that breath you know I'm that bit
I'm that I'm that sugary little
freshener I'm that sugary fresh and I'll
put you know my finger I put two you
know I brush my hands along your along
your cheeks and make your breath smell
nice peppermint pads not a real person
but in my mind it was real remember
Halloween was also a chance I remember
it was a chance to go door-to-door in
your neighborhood and see what the [ __ ]
was going on remember that you get to
some people's house you like Dan they
don't have any furniture
I remember we open one one person open
the door is just a garage their whole
house was just a garage like what are
y'all y'all sleeping in that Ford
Explorer the hell is going on but you
kind of got to see what was going on in
different people's lives man it was
interesting it was really really
interesting but happy early Halloween
I'm excited you know I get excited for
the holidays and I get excited you know
I love the holidays you know I love
things that bring people together and I
think that the holidays is one of those
things and and I think we all need it I
think we all need it I want to make a
couple of little announcements you know
the King and the sting podcast is coming
if you want to submit some artwork
that you know you can email us through
the website or you can send a Brendan
Schaub or myself a DM and you know we're
just looking for some cool we want neat
artwork King and the sting K 80s and
that's it so if you want to submit
something you know be a part of it you
know take a shot at it you know there's
no guarantees or anything but we are
looking for you know neat ideas and this
podcast is going to be user driven so
you'll be able to submit videos for king
of the sting that will that will you can
present themes you can have stuff for us
to discuss and/or to battle against each
other you know like dominoes verse Pizza
we use that example before or you know
dolphins verse you know dolphins verse
children that are on swim teams it could
be anything and you'll be able to
present those opportunities to us you
know outer space verse inner space you
know chakras verse planets you'll be
able to presenting any of those things
and we'll break them down so it's all
gonna be user driven and we're excited
about that and that's gonna be king in
the sting podcast and it's coming up
soon we don't know when but probably
within about the next I would say within
two weeks we should have the first
episode out what else is going on I want
to say thank you for the people that are
on reddit and subreddit
somebody sent me an email the other day
and just said that a lot of people have
been on there and it's been really
exciting and an exciting you know people
commenting and being a part of that as
well the Facebook group for this past
weekend is you know is is is is
tremendous and we have a lot of those
people that will come out to shows and
support and help sell merch and and just
be a part of things man and I just feel
and I meet so many nice people you know
I feel honestly so lucky I meet so many
nice people that come out and they want
to talk about this past week and they
want to talk about an experience that
they had or they want to talk about a
struggle that's going on in their life
and I want to listen and I want to be a
part of that as much as I can
you know I really appreciate it
I really really appreciate I think we're
gonna be able to do some neat stuff
together and I know I keep saying that
but slowly those things come into
fruition we're gonna go on to Charlotte
this weekend and I'll be there if you
have any friends in Charlotte tell them
to come on out it's not sold out but
it's getting close and that's October
fourth through six at the comedy zone
and we're gonna try got Ari Maness
coming and Ari was an original sidekick
on this podcast for a few episodes a
while back and he's been a nice friend
over the years and he's a very funny
comedian he's going to come and help
we're gonna do the we're gonna do the
money for the cleaning lady in the room
in the hotel room you know I know
there's women work hard and and for
years I didn't tip those ladies when I
would leave home because I don't have
any money and now you know I'm able to
leave that five ten dollars that's what
that $20 or you know meet her in the
hallway and just say thank you and leave
a little bit of money so we're gonna be
we're gonna our goal is and we may fail
at this our goal is to hide money in the
hotel room like before she's gonna come
in and clean just basically say do you
want to be on a like I guess a
hidden-camera game show maybe and then
see how it breaks down where she you
know it's coming back okay you have one
minute we hid money in the room cash and
now we're it's you have this much time
to find it and then we're gonna have
cameras that social would be able to
watch her try and find the money which I
think will just be a different
experience for her being in a hotel room
and being able to mess it up and look
for cash so that should be fun man that
should be a fun experience I don't know
if that's the best way to do things or
what it is or what our plan is but our
plan is just you know to help help a
lady that probably works really hard
make a little bit extra cash so I want
to thank our patreon errs for supporting
us on that and and contributing to make
those types of things happen so you know
we use the money to be able to fly ari
there and and help and have him help
produce it over the weekend so I'm
pretty excited
what else any other announcements I
think that's that's kind of what's going
on that's kind of what's going on what
did I do this weekend um oh I went and
got that PRP so some of you guys know
you know about a year or so ago I got
hair restoration you they take part of
your hair and your hair is just you know
what your hair is just like uh your hair
is just it's like a it's like a pieces
of fabric that grow out of your body and
it's really remarkable when you think
about it that your body is almost like a
planet and you know how a planet has
like a forest here and like a pond here
and they have water here your body's
just like that your body is like a
planet you know in some place that have
a forest at the top and have a you know
a little forest around your around your
wiener and on a planet a wiener would be
like a volcano and then they have you
know you have lakes and like whirlpools
and those are like your eyes and mouth
that you would those would be on a
planet it would be like a lake or a
sinkhole or a geyser your mouth might be
a geyser if for our on you know the
synonym of it for you know your body
being a planet your butthole would be
maybe a crater or a like a dirty wishing
well if somebody had a real dirty
wishing well in some town or something
like that but I say that just because
like hair is basically like you know so
I got that hair surgery and they took
you know they basically did
reforestation and reforestation is when
you take a little bit of a forest and
you move it somewhere else only if
you've ever like I remember one time I
stayed at a double tree and I stole all
the plants out of the lobby and put them
in my hotel room over the weekend or
over like two weeks I was there for two
weeks working on a television show and I
took the big big beautiful plants went
out I mean these is you know these plant
pots were three feet across four feet
across and now got them all and I got a
mama Dali and got him up to my room
so my room looked like a jungle you know
the lobby looked a little sparse boy
but uh but but my room looked like a
jungle and that's called reforestation
when you move plants around and that's
what they do so I got the hair surgery a
while back they took a hair out of the
back of my head cuz you know I'm full
back here I mean I got something if I
mean if you know the animals when I
Drive by you can see animals coming to
the edge by the highway because they see
this [ __ ] bad they see this bad crop
I got Rock and I'm that crop rocker I'm
you know I got soy bean sugar cane
hanging off the back of my head piece
you know my skull bro if they ever do my
skull at science at a science place or a
scientific Center I mean they're never
gonna be able to get the hair off the
skull that's how my [ __ ] that my [ __ ] is
in there a lot of my hair starts at my
spine grows up through my brain out my
head bone or my skull and into the world
but animals they sense that they know
when they see that you know when they
see that gumption rocking through when
they see that I got the balls to grow
the falls daddy and anyway they for Pete
for anyway for a year ago I got the hair
transplant they take the hair out and
they put some of it in the front and I
wasn't losing my hair I just you know
I've said this before I love surgery you
know I love little surgeries I like
being in there they make you feel taken
care of you get there they care about
who you are you know they write down
your information and they have like a
nurse that checks on you it just made me
feel really cared for and so that's what
I always liked about them and and so
anyway you have to go back in though
once a year and and and they take stem
cells they take blood out of your arm
and they basically pick an all-star team
out of your blood in a machine that make
like picks like all-star basically they
get all the Dominique Wilkins is out of
your blood you know like they put they
they send the Lonzo balls elsewhere but
they take all the you know the kobe
bryant's and the Chris Mullins and the
you know the penny Hardaway's the aunt
ferny's and they take all of those as
all
our teams and they inject them in your
scalp and then it makes your hair stay
fresh and you know keeps that moisture
going so that's what I did that's what I
did so if you saw my Instagram that I
was doing this treatment it was it's
called PRP and they and that's what they
do and one of the funny and they it's
after you get the hair transplant which
I did last year they put some of my
mullet right in the front so some of the
front front of my hair even though I
don't know if you could tell at all cuz
I can't even tell I mean [ __ ] it might
not even have been effective but some of
the front front of my hair is actually
the back of my hair and so to just be
able to know that if you you know you
got that hockey haircut you got that
mole mole you got that thing that when
you break it out of a cap or out of a
hat when you you know if raccoons see it
it makes them want to [ __ ] that's the
kind of hair I have dude I'll take my
[ __ ] for a walk at night all the
raccoons that are just looking through
dumpsters so there's always that one
weird Raccoonus in the recycling bin
like you know looking at a book or
something remember that that raccoon is
a what is wrong with that raccoon that
you know but but they have but that but
when when I walk by at night with my
hair out that you see those animals
[ __ ] so I know that I have something
going on out here on the top of my head
and I want to take care of it and that's
what the PRP treatment is they inject it
back in and my this doctor that I met in
Los Angeles was great you know he's a
great dude he's really cool he used to
do liver transplants and my sister had a
liver transplant when I was young we
bonded on that aspect and then we went
from there but as what's going on I'm
excited about King in the sting what
else happened we had let's get into a
few calls man let's get into a few calls
I wanna let you know that this episode
is brought to you by grey block pizza
gray block pizza and bronx-born pizza
which is in Bend Oregon gray block which
is in Los Angeles on Pico Boulevard my
friend Ruben sent me a picture on
Instagram the other day of he and his
wife over at gray block while they were
visiting Los Angeles and I was grateful
for that
you for sharing that with me one of my
good friends is the owner of that place
but yeah I love Halloween growing up I
loved Halloween I just loved being young
and I loved at that time when you could
you weren't everything wasn't so
judgmental you know we let people
breathe a little bit we let people be
human you know and you got to be human
enough so that it actually meant
something on Halloween when you got to
be a beast or you got to be a a
scientist or you got to be a bumblebee
or a rat it got to it meant something
because you it's like you were like oh
tonight I get to creep out you know I
get to I get to you know I'm enough of a
human that I get to creep out out you
know I get to be I get to be a creep now
I get to be a you know it is something
that is scary
[Music]
and there was value in that because it
was the one night you could do it but
now people out here [ __ ]
trick-or-treat everybody everybody's is
some people so angry out in the world
they Halloween and every day every day
they leave their house as a as a
Frankenstein and Frankenstein was a man
if he was Jewish or German Stein
Steiners time one of them I think one or
the other but yeah he was like maybe a
Jewish man or a German man that had bad
skin I think and I think he also got
electrocuted by his friend and they I
think shared an apartment I'm not
exactly sure but but it was fun back
then because you could it was a night to
be something different it was a night to
be something different and I loved it
man I loved Halloween this episode is
brought to you by better help calm it is
professional and affordable counseling
and if you need counseling and
considering counseling you're afraid to
maybe go to an actual counselor in your
town or
city you're afraid to talk to a spouse
about maybe going to counseling or a
friend and I found I found better help
to be better and helpful and especially
a great starter way to get into going to
therapy I go to therapy you know I
currently go to to two therapists and
it's helpful for me will always need it
I don't know but for right now it's
helpful in my life and you can go to
better help calm slash Theo th EO it's
available worldwide you can interact
with a therapist through desktop mobile
app FaceTime you can send messages you
can schedule video and audio sessions so
it's a good way if you aren't sure if
therapy or something is right for you
but you may need help with something
it's a good way to get into that world
and check it out better help calm slash
Theo what else what else what else let's
get into some calls here this we have we
have last week we had a guy who called
in and even having some issues you know
and he called in at the end of the
podcast and was struggling with
addiction and with some you know because
the addiction is the dark arts and
that's Voldemort living in the neighbor
young Nick and imagine having something
evil just living in the in your net
casting spells casting spells inside of
you
spells that you carry out a lot in your
life even though you don't want to and
we had a man that called in last week a
father you know he was five days sober
and he'd been struggling with some
issues with his wife and feeling like he
was gonna lose his child and and we got
we had a couple of responses that came
into that and wha-la
will tap in a one right here this is
Jasmine onward hey Theo I'm jasmine I'm
from Calabasas California and this is
Jasmine is thank you for calling Jasmine
and this is on our video you can see
this on youtube you will be able to see
the actual video and you can submit
videos to the website through theof on
calm as well onward pollen in because I
heard Alaska
Davin from Montana and going through
some dark times with alcohol and like
and have not drink alcohol in ten months
now and I'm just I didn't I'm living the
best life now and Oh congratulations
Jasmine she says she's ten months now
off of alcohol and alcohol is liquid
fire batter I mean if you don't know
what alcohol does your child or
something and you're listening to this
which honestly I recommend dude you know
what I'm saying this could be that
dangerous thing that kids listen to
sometimes this show but alcohol is
basically pouring fire basically pouring
the devil's sweat right into your dam
just in here really into your soul
holster onward so maybe some insight on
early recovery time is gonna feel really
long right now I was a blackout drinker
so you know and now I have to live
through all those hours and I'd be like
oh my god like this is so long like but
it gets better and it goes back to
normal and it's just the first few
months um - your brain is gonna do
everything he can right now to regulate
itself without alcohol so you're gonna
feel a lot of feelings it's gonna feel
really like maybe irrational erratic my
tip is write that [ __ ] down or do put it
in a voice memo or something to get it
out of your brain because if it stays in
your brain it's gonna feel like it's
your personality or it's it's a trait
that you have and it's not it's it's
just what's going on right now
Wow those are uh that's really true
that's yeah if you it's wild how your
thoughts like yeah you feel like that's
the truth and especially a lot of times
you're going through early recovery
you're in there struggler and even if
you're gonna some regular life sometimes
you get haunted you get the ghosts man
and especially when you're taking off a
time off of alcohol or getting into
sobriety yeah you got a lot of time to
kill that's time before were you was at
the bar he was ordering that you know
you know that Rumple Minze
Canadian tuck away you know with that
splash a lime lime or something that's
when you were having nine beers or
something you know
petting of your buddy's cat or whatever
or you know trying to touch a mousetrap
getting real high and trying to touch a
mousetrap and be that brave finger you
know Napoleon Bonaparte of finger fronts
so it's it is it's a lot of free time
and if you know you got to be careful
with your free time but like she's
saying if you're writing this stuff down
you're getting it out of your head
because a sheet of paper can really be
your head in front of you and it's hard
to look at your head when you are when
you are in your head so if you can write
things down and put your head out in
front of you then you can really get a
different perspective but
congratulations jasmine ten months and
and that's that is some that's some
sweet suggestions there for Devin yeah
he was really really struggling and I
got to get in touch with him actually
I'll have to make sure to see how he's
doing what else let's keep it cruising
here we had another call actually a
suggestion for Devin and let's get into
that one here we go do a thought Bubba
this is a Devin down in Georgia man
Paulding County Oh Devin from Georgia
and this is Devin for Devin because the
guy who called in last week was Devin
homeward gang gang i calling in now i
was listening to the last episode
there's another guy named Evan he's
don't do some things dude but one Devin
do another man just telling her you can
make it I use this past weekend and the
church I use a lot of you guys podcast
man get through everyday but I have to
for you not getting to see my daughter
man I got it last weekend I get to go to
every soccer practice I love it man it's
worthwhile keep doing what you're doing
Theo and Devin hold in and man you got
it
Wow excuse me there Wow four years he
still you got to see his daughter you
know he gets to go to soccer practice
and he said hold in there and that's it
man I said look that look this might be
your Halloween like Jasmine's saying you
can have these ghosts in your head you
know you're gonna have that Frankenstein
or Stein you know you're gonna have you
know somebody's dret you know little
silane a dress like a
pregnant you're gonna have these things
in your head they're gonna be haunting
you and you got to hold the line you
know you got to jump in it you know you
you're in the grass now you know you
ain't you ain't still out there running
and jumping in the dark hydrants like
Daniel like little goatee Daniel you got
an opportunity you're in the grass and
you just got you have to trudge along
Devin you have to trudge along to get to
that front door to get that snicker I
know that's how crazy correlation and
I'm not I don't really you know it's
just a core it's just a silly
correlation but what I'm saying is it
that other people can do it
this man Devin did it down in Georgia
dude if he can do it in Georgia you can
do it in somewhere else because
different places are just different
places there's different pieces of land
and you can do it man you know but it's
nice to know that you have people out
there that are thinking about you
writing home and you got this play boy
you got this and we got to check in with
each other I'm a checking with you as
soon as this show is over the the
hotline is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three you can always call
the hotline and leave your thoughts
suggestions feelings what's going on in
your life you know we're out here we're
out here and thank you guys for calling
being a part of this show let's take
another call here onward steel shell
riff coming out of California
what's up Alvarez man homework wondering
not what you think about I got fired
last week I'm a maintenance mechanic
electrician AC guy certified welder so
I'm on this boom lift they call me down
and tell me to go working this on this
toilet which I usually don't do toilets
pull the feces massive mountain bro
oh yeah bruh then boo boo cauldrons and
I used to work at a place broad that
they had you know I used to work at this
place called duck O's when I was young
and it was like a burger joint and it
was only in business for probably two
months which I don't even know you could
be in business for two months I mean
that seemed like almost not even a
business it seemed like somebody just
having people stopped by and then
getting a little bit
their money and that's it but so duck
owes they had burgers and cheeseburgers
and they had the famous for and that's
what it was called and it was four
pieces of meat cheese on the top cheese
on the bottom and that was the big thing
I like oh we're gonna put cheese on the
bottom of the burger that famous for and
do people would get sick from it I guess
I don't know if something's wrong with
the meat or something's going with the
bread or just some was wrong with
[ __ ] duck oh and the whole joint so
I'm in there Brahmas a counter boy but
that's the funny thing look when there's
only two people and employees and one of
them the boss they hire you as the
counter boy next thing you know you
ain't Nair
next thing you know you in there in the
toilet with that you know that plunger
and you and they're just [ __ ]
ratatouille next thing you know you're
working in that boo boo kitchen you work
in the toilets shift because they don't
have anybody else
and the owner one act like he's never
dealt with you know and like he's never
dealt with fie see and even though the
crazy thing is he's the one making the
food and selling it he's the one making
people sick and now I'm having to work
in the back streets of this
establishment in the seedy underbelly of
his own customers and dude it was the
smallest little restaurant had three
tables so people would order from me go
sit down get sick then go use in the
bathroom there was no some time you get
a bathroom there's like a little waiting
here you open the door there's another
little room and or a hallway and then
the bathrooms this [ __ ] was just door
toilet no what no it was just gender new
can go in there but um you could go in
there if it wanted to
and so you would he it was just so
bizarre but you would people would be
sick in there and it's like I'm
literally trying to take an order and
like 11 feet away from me through some
very very limited ply wall or whatever
it's called plywood very very limited
plywood you could hear somebody making
just some damn you know just that body
belt
you know making a belt out of his bottom
and just sweating and feeling really
really iottery mind you're feeling
iottery but your booty gets Jamaican
breath sometimes you're sweating so hard
don't wit me onward
like I like though the time of the door
don't use it and some do did that I see
no toilet paper all I seen was feces oh
that's a booty terrorist breath I've
been in there somebody dude I was at an
armed Falcons game one time and they had
a urinal with the bag over you know they
do that they put that plastic bag this
dude put turned his butt around you know
cut a little hole in that bag he had a
you know a sharp object or something a
little ship or a piece of bone in his
pocket he cut a little thing in that
plastic and boo-booed right into the
deal unbelievable people living out in
the world nom word so I'm like I'm not
doing that
you said the supervisor goes till 5:00
to do we don't need you here I do a lot
for you Joe because I also go to school
night trying to get my long-term goals
here my Masters in Social Work Oh
congratulations man I love hearing that
hours I love hearing that brother that's
what you want to do Social Work land
you want to help other people you know
homeward uh try to help gun I'm the 11
years clean trying to go that route you
know right now yeah so uh he helps me I
want to have to intern I'm doing some
interning at dry cleaning but I'm like I
help you - I work 16 hours it's equal
I'm not saying anything i'm just not
cleaning a toilet filled with [ __ ] i'm
not doing that he got all mad i fires me
so now i'm without a job it's been about
three four days and i started getting
depressed i start getting weird like a
man used to work but i don't know what
you think or what other guys think up
there so i talked to some friends
they're like you should have just did it
but I thought that's where's the line I
have a three-year-old daughter someday
I'm gonna tell her you got to do what
you feels right self-respect is very
important but you know not having a job
is a horrible horrible feeling I got
some things lined up but I hoped here on
the podcast man I'm all about you bro
well thanks for calling that's a tough
spot because yeah you have the child I
think you know you take a couple of
options I think you can always go back
to him if you still feel like
you know sometimes it's about being the
bigger man you know and maybe it was you
know in that day sometimes you're
feeling a certain way you could always
go back and say look I made a mistake
you know I could have done it
differently I could have said I could
have just taken the direction I just
felt like that was out of line for me
I've been there you know that had to do
it I used to wash dishes at this fancy
place called Dakotas when I was growing
up and one sometime they had a system
manager or something in there he tried
to make me eat a little bucket of Our
Lives lime slices and I don't even not
barely knew this man he was always
trying to pretend he was French and [ __ ]
but he wasn't and he was probably an
idiot
or an idiot uh that's French I don't
know but anyway he tried to give me to
eat this thing aligns and said I had to
do it cuz I was an employee man [ __ ]
that bruh I ain't eatin us you know they
probably had 60 lime slices in there and
I probably I was a child mal was
probably sixteen I never had more than
even one lime slice and this man trying
to give me 60 lime slices and I and I
had to quit so someone's got to stand up
for yourself and you got to be a man and
that's okay man there's something going
on in this world where it's like you
can't be a man these days so you can
stand up for yourself and you can even
go back they even more manly if you want
to do it or as manly you could go back
to the dude if you feel differently in a
few days and say hey I could have
handled that differently
would you consider us working again
that way is still you're meeting
somebody halfway you're not giving in
you know it's nice to be out I mean it's
the you know the most manly thing to do
sometimes is to [ __ ] get over that
little hurdle but in the moment yeah
they got you down there cleaning out
somebody else's you know dirty [ __ ]
booty aquarium come on get out of there
I'd be out I'd be out so I don't blame
you you know hold it down you know for
as long as you can and then when you
have to you know if you feel like you
know maybe take a look at some other
opportunities you said you're going back
to school so I'm sure it's probably you
know I'm sure you're in some tight calm
fines there with work I would if you're
okay with it I would probably
reappropriation and I think that they
would respect you could say just say
cleanly like look I needed a couple days
to cool off man because the booty work
around here was a little too hot for
daddy to be down there doing you know
suddenly you out there and you to some
little boo-boo ratatouille and you see
you know just out there working out and
some you know and somebody else's
porridge tank come on but thank you for
calling man and I love the fact that
you're moving forward do you ever plan
in your life you want to be do social
work you have a daughter you're already
thinking ahead about that you want to
tell your daughter that you stood up for
yourself that you're not afraid to be
stand up for yourself I love that I love
that man it's really really a powerful
message and I appreciate you calling in
oh man what else let's go on man onward
let's take another call right here oh we
had a another video call that came in
let's get that hitter right here hi Theo
my name is also Theo oh that's beautiful
so from you know dos we got just a
odorous homework and I am 30 years old I
am from Kansas City Kansas City I'm
trying to come out there soon onward
musician just a professional
multi-instrumentalist and I am also in
transgender man I've you know I've been
transitioning from female to male okay
you go in female to male
okay homework first off I just wanted to
say like thanks for just thanks for your
podcast thanks for putting yourself out
there cuz I've been listening to you for
maybe about like less than two months
and it's really been helping me a lot
oh that's sweet of you to say that I
appreciate you saying that I'll work
through my mental health problems
that I've been dealing with this year so
thank you for that oh I can imagine if
you transitioning from one section to
another I can't even imagine the mental
health part of it
jeepers dude I can't even you know I'll
watch an episode of of uh of Sex in the
City and I can barely hold it together
sometimes
so homeward I was curious being a
transgender guy I do not know the first
thing about like being a dude I don't I
know I don't know how to approach the
social aspect of it even though that's
exactly like how I feel and so I was
wondering if you know maybe you had any
advice or any of it you know especially
advice on how not to like seem creepy or
weird because I know people are gonna
start thinking that now they don't
generally think that women but they will
think it of men and I really don't want
to come across like that so that's
pretty much it yeah well thanks again
yeah thanks for calling know this is
super interesting how do you get yeah
how do you be a dude well you showed up
at a really wild time young lady I don't
know I mean I almost want to say right
now it might be safer to go back across
the river you know it's a scary time to
be a man right now but at the same time
I'm gonna do it you know and you're
gonna do it and I commend you that's got
to be really really brave you know I've
never been you know I've locked my keys
in my car
you know but I've I can only imagine if
you locked your you know if you feel
like God kind of locked your your gender
keys and you know in the vehicle and you
you got to pop that lock and you know
and maybe and renegotiate the ignition a
little you know they to be a guy these
days I mean I think first of all you
got to get some cool some kind of like
maybe some nice slacks you know and nice
some nice pants I think I hat if you
like to do a hat some guys do a hat I
think these days guys are a lot more
supportive of each other than they used
to be I don't think have to do steroids
anymore so you don't have to do that you
can i think getting into sports is super
good you know even if you just watch as
a fan playing some fantasy sports and it
might not be something that you like but
i mean i guess you're asking for things
that i think make it easier to associate
with other men so those are some of them
being able to talk about sports being
able to you know UFC that kind of stuff
at first I didn't like watching UFC I
don't like watching people really beat
each other but then you start to see
that a lot of these men are heroes and
that they have goals and they have
ambitions and the fighting is just the
way that they it's just there it's their
physical process of chasing their dreams
and so I started to really enjoy it more
when I look at it like that how else to
be a guy I would say maybe spit on the
ground sometimes you could do chewing
tobacco if you want I don't recommend it
because you get hooked into the tobacco
world but I used to do it for a while I
worked on a farm and I didn't feel like
that much of a guy had to guy up a
little bit and then so I stuff a couple
you know socks in my junk area buttocks
by that by that [ __ ] you know by that
little meat tongue you know that that
low tongue that you got that Weiner and
I put a couple socks in there and start
doing chewing tobacco because I was
trying to bulk out and man up a little
bit I've done a lot of things to try to
seem manly over the years so how do you
welcome over to the boys side of minutes
wow this is like the craziest game of
Red Rover I've ever been in you know let
me catch your name again at the
beginning it was also Theo oh [ __ ] at
least I maybe I'm not egotistical enough
that I don't remember in this sense
because it's my own name but do welcome
you know wow I get to welcome a Theo to
the man to be in a man being
adult male look it's uh it's tough these
days though you're not especially in
your white guy so you know you're
getting if they're gonna blame you for
everything you know if you even if you
didn't do something you could be blamed
for it
but people are the media right now does
not like you so you got to be careful so
just be careful you know be cognizant of
what's going on I don't know if it's a
safe time to look a woman in the eyes a
lot of women out there in certain cities
most of America you still can some place
is a little dangerous so I would just be
a little bit weary out there but welcome
over to the man's side you know we can
use some good men over here and it's
nice to see that they got women coming
over to this side you know because we've
had up we've logged we've had a lot of
men slip over on to the other side you
rarely see that bad you know that bad
boy coming back over here but Red Rover
Red Rover send Theo right over and all
aboard and welcome thank you for calling
in and that's got to be a brave journey
you know I've done some different things
in my life Community College uh you know
I got poison ivy you know I had my penis
hole kind of enlarged when I was young
I've tried to learn Spanish about six
times but I've never been through
anything like that and I bet that that's
that's the Mount Olympus really of CIM
you know you're doing it all you're
doing it oh boy that remodel huh
whoo Red Rover Red Rover sent do write
over and look if you learned anything
while you were over there get over here
and tell us because they've taken these
men out right now every viewer may have
you even I'm thinking about mailing my
dick to another country and going and
getting it later so you might be coming
across at the wrong time but no matter
what we're happy to have you and uh and
that's a beauty you know that's a wild
journey you're on and and I love you
Theo and welcome Theo
that's crazy it's like I'm almost like
I'm talking to myself okay let's take
another call here what a week
what's up feel it's reversed um and I'm
in London whoa Ernesto from London huh
onward just came back from the Chris
D'Elia show it was alright and we were
sitting here and we were thinking we had
an idea for a show for you and it goes
yovan describes the video for someone
with visual disabilities so they can't
see so you have to describe the video
for them like as a helpful gesture ok so
wait so I described a video for somebody
with visual difficulties like blind
syndrome ok so I have to describe a
video for them or can I describe
anything that's what I want to know
that's the thing you know I would love
to describe things imagine being a
describer imagine being a seeing-eye dog
for a blind person but you're a
seeing-eye person which thought things
better you know it's kind of [ __ ] up
I'll say it we get blind people a dog
hey guy you can't see anything here's a
dog how about a real person that walks
around and helps them out you know you
got a bathroom buddy you got one you
know a kid needs to go to the bathroom
you send him in pairs but a blind guy
needs to go for the rest of his life and
you tie a damn you know a bichon or a
you know a little baby Australian
Shepherd to his hand and Australian
Shepherd I think is actually could
handle the job a bichon did if your
seeing-eye dog is a [ __ ] Bichon bro
you're not gonna make it and you're not
gonna make it far maybe you might make
it to like a you know a place like a
French restaurant but look I could do it
man I'd love to describe something to a
blind person a marshmallow come on dude
I would love to describe a cliff imagine
describing a cliff like a not like a man
named Clifford but like a scary place
where you can walk and then you keep and
if you keep walking then you're not then
it's that's it imagine yeah like I
wonder if blind people went because if I
get by the edge of a cliff my whole
body just like is like do not go
anywhere right here and what if that
happens with blind people you know I
want to get actually you know what if
you know someone who is blind in the Los
Angeles area and I'm a hundred percent
serious here please hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three you know because I'm tired of
wondering what it's like I'm tired of
having questions for blind people and
not being able to talk to him because
people mad oh it's insensitive you can't
ask a blind person about being blind I
can't why not
yes I can if you know what blind person
that lives in Los Angeles California
we'll fly them down you know we'll get
them around here I'd love to have be
able to have the opportunity to talk to
someone who has that ailment and see
what's going on and uh and do and I'm
gonna admit you know and I don't mean
that in a jovial way you know cuz I
don't know if I'll see forever you know
when I think about my life honestly I
don't always know if I'll have my sight
you know sometimes when I think about
thirty years down the road or even ten
twelve thirteen years I don't know if I
I don't know if my eyes work the same as
they do now so we would love to have
somebody on that has that ability but
yeah you know but to describe things to
a blonde I would love to maybe be able
to do that if I had enough extra time it
to do that type of work but I think it's
a beautiful job you know to get somebody
out there or even a little uh you know
even get like a little blind they have
those you know those sex those goats
that do sex and then faint which I
fashioned a lot of you know I've
fashioned my sexual style over because I
get so nervous I'd hold my breath during
sex and then just get so keyed up I'd
[ __ ] just be unconscious onward let's
take another call hey Bo what's going on
it's um it's Brendon from Atlanta I just
wanted to call and let you know that
you're the man bro and you don't need to
you don't need to feel like you need to
do anything bigger for us exactly what
you do helps us in the community that
watches you each and every day you know
thanks for calling Brendon from Atlanta
let's hear
more I'm a little nervous right now but
that's okay man don't feel nervous dude
I appreciate you calling I think it's
nice you to call I think it is yeah I
could imagine is probably kind of
nervous but if we ever meet each other
in person don't feel nervous around me
you know and if you do just tell me that
because I don't want anybody to ever
have to feel nervous around me you know
you know I'm not special
you know I'm not a special person you
know I'm just somebody that's just
trying to be a [ __ ] person and it's
really hard these days to be a person
it's hard to be a young man it's hard to
be a young man if you struggled and
don't even know how to be a man
sometimes you know in this the
environment we're trying to learn in but
by being here by you calling in brothers
I really appreciate it's here more you
know we don't even notice the [ __ ]
you know we don't even notice like when
you say you feel like you might not be
having a good show or you feel like some
things might just go wrong we just want
to see you grow you know the same so I
keep on keeping on gang gang you already
know what it is and I hope that you
having a good day today bro you know all
right right thanks Burning Man thanks
for that yeah second-guess myself a lot
you know I think I've always had a lot
of trouble my whole life and being
decision making decisions I don't know
I'm not very you know nobody ever taught
me how to make a decision when I was
young I was making my own decisions and
so I created my own reasoning in my head
for why things go the way that they do
or why I choose and sometimes that a lot
of times when I was young it was selfish
reasons and I didn't realize it was
selfish reasons I just needed to survive
I needed to get by you know I needed to
be able to get some sleep at night and
so you know you do whatever you have to
do to get into a comfortable place you
know inside of yourself and sometimes
you create dirty stairwells or misguided
you create stairwells that you know
don't always connect to floors and stuff
you create your own little belief system
inside of you that makes you be able to
function and survive and
again so now I'm an adult and I'm still
have this you know some of the contract
and working side of me is a little
shoddy because I [ __ ] did it all
myself as a child or I did it with
strange influences and you know so yeah
I guess I just get nervous sometimes and
you know when I do feel pressure as I
get older now feel pressure as this
podcast gets bigger listenership you
know cuz I don't want to fail I don't
know if this is interesting it's like I
don't I don't I don't think I said I
don't want to film myself I just you
know it's something that I went this
podcast always feel small you know and
because to me a lot of times it feels
kind of one-on-one in some ways you know
like I'll be I'll be honest I don't know
who you are Brennan but in my head I
picture you call I picture maybe a young
black guy or a mix guy uh you know maybe
in a Honda Honda Accord bruh but LX you
know maybe ducked off somewhere behind a
subway or Quiznos bruh [ __ ] subway dude
how every subway has a B rating on the
door and every now and then you see a
roach by the meat or a bug and you
pretend like you don't come on but yeah
maybe ducked off somewhere and calling
into the hotline so now that could be
totally fictional I don't know there you
could be I mean who knows you know you
could be a woman who knows but but I
appreciate you calling man and thanks
for saying that yeah I guess I I just
want to be I don't want to waste
somebody's time that's what I don't want
to do so I don't want somebody listening
to the show and like aw man it's dudes
wasting my [ __ ] time that's what I
don't want for some reason in my life
I've always felt like that like I did
something like man I hope I'm not
wasting somebody's time I think maybe
you know when I was young people the
people you know I think my mom was so
busy and how to work so much that
you know I felt like I was always under
the gun emotionally or even with time
wise with her so I maybe that's why I
feel that way now like I just hope I'm
not wasting somebody's time I always
feel that way a little bit but thank you
for calling man I appreciate you and the
ATL I hope to be able to come there in
the spring and thanks your support you
know I'm gonna [ __ ] up on this podcast
I'm not gonna Simas a [ __ ] people don't
agree with I don't even know you know I
don't even know sometimes but we got men
coming over to our side we got another
Theo in the books now so this is city
[ __ ] we have we heating up boy we got
this army baby
um let's go to another call home word
hey Theo gang gang this is a Derek Allen
cone from Vancouver Canada dirty Derek
from Vancouver Sun you dad snowy bad boy
that you that a Domino bull cat daddy
you up there in the snow and snow think
about snow dude think about if a lake
just jumped up into the air and made
itself coldest [ __ ] and then fell on
everybody
a savage bruh mother nature ain't mother
nature is Slytherin everybody out here
you know you know looking at the flowers
in June you know thinking this bad
[ __ ] all Gryffindor and then suddenly
come February mother nature to lift him
[ __ ] a lake senator sky ice and those
things out in the shatter in them
[ __ ] and dropping them on the
people's lives and that's what you get
in Canada thank you for calling onward
that was calling it looking for some
advice pretty much I've been talking to
this lady you know she's traveling
across Canada coming across to live here
in my province of Ontario oh yeah and in
Canada a lot of times he's these ladies
up there they got some mad matches up
there they travel they got you know
little dogs in front of them these are
these little these are dinner otters in
these Iditarod Erza's and when you have
a bunch of it's you ever seen 101
Dalmatians
it's a movie it's like this angry
lady she's a can think she's like a coat
salesman or like a fashion designer and
she kidnaps a bunch of animals from the
fire station and they strike back bruh
does little does dog strike back and
they're angry and everything well but
apparently some of these women they use
husky animals up in Canada and they're
forward moving and they that's how a lot
of women will travel around Canada
because I guess a safer than air travel
or something I'm not sure enough to look
into it's called I did or rotting
homeward and anyways a matter before
matter few months back there's always
overdoing work over there ok so you met
this girl opening up a shoe store
together you know who that Al Bundy dude
in a shoe think about it you got a shoes
I mean nowadays are you probably just
and 11 feet away while the woman tries
the shoe on but back in the day boy used
to you could get up there you know touch
that heel maybe this little this little
piggy went to market you know this
little piggy had none
remember it a hat piggy what the [ __ ]
was that piggy doing this little piggy
had roast beef what the [ __ ] I got to
investigate that [ __ ] let's hear more
boy you got al bundy of the north sun
breaking tension when we were working
together
so anyways - now she's driving over and
so I get to talking and she's we're
talking about some of that raunchy stuff
you know again getting in some dirty tat
yeah and that's dark arts especially in
Canada breath probably not even that
raunchy it's like OD ever uh maybe put
on a maybe a hat that's a little too
tight Oh have you ever um you know if
you ever been you know making chocolate
milk and instead of one scoop of powder
you put two scoops of powder I'm just
joking love Canada more dirty shot and
she goes she asking how many how many
ladies I've been with to it so I answer
three which is commendable I think three
is the male answer you go three or you
go seven that's it
three if you're under 24 you go three if
you're in your 30s you go seven and if
you're between 24 and 30
brah you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on anyway so just wait you get you
know to one of those ages and figure it
out more
I'm the 25 year old guy oh yeah so well
you sound like a nice guy yeah 25 as a
kid yeah an American 24 so that's a
Canadian 25 more and then to which she
replies she goes oh uh I was with three
as well multiply it by seven so now I'm
thinking oh this 21 guys with a lot of
guys you know so anyways now I'm trying
to be an adult about this is a cute girl
she's a couple years younger than me uh
you know that's pretty much my story man
thanks Bo keep doing your thing man look
the podcast dang 101 dick nations huh
she's been taking in just make sure she
don't have any spots on her pup bro
that's all I'm saying
you know it's interesting this makes me
think is sex still what's the value of
it does it still have the same emotional
value as it once had and I think to some
people it does and some people it
doesn't and some people just their
perspective of sex is totally different
to some people you know some people you
never have sex you don't it's not a you
know it's like this hidden oracle to you
and some people who have sex all the
time it's it's more of a comfortable
thing if you're nervous about your body
then sex is one way to you where if
you're comfortable or you by your body
sex is another way if your parents you
know grew up in the 60s they may be very
sexual or have be very open about stuff
and you may have been raised that way
whereas if you parents grew up in you
know in in a rural town or in the you
know with us Church where things is real
you know they got pictures and like you
know snakes and stuff on the wall and
everything then they you know people
might be a little bit more risque about
playing freeze tag with you with your
crotch with another crotch so it's you
know it's different everybody's sex is
different so you know she could make it
22 and you can make it four if you don't
want to be like that but what I do like
is is that you're willing to not judge
her on that x is differ it's a different
time now and people are just different
some people are in America they you know
they went on a sex their whole lives
they might not do anything a lot of
these women out and you know a lot of
women nowadays it is filling their
vaginas with cement and hiring an
attorney to stand out front
they not even let many they you know
it's crazy so look I'm just glad you
have an open conversation with this girl
she sounds fun bra
you know she sounds fun tell him freakin
come over to the house you let her you
know water to water her dogs a little
bit maybe she'll teach you some things
she's like the Danica Patrick Cox out
there she's been doing laps around the
old you know dick Stadium so I think
it's cool man she sounds cute but in
that car every any girl sounds cute bro
hey let me tell you about this girl
oh she fought this sounds hot does she
have a friend that's every dude let's
hear more on word another call another
call
yo Co big t dawg what's up t dog
homework this is your other T Donald
Trey from Portland Oregon what's up tre
from Portland onward you know I've been
you know as the only black man in
Portland other than the Trailblazers and
probably one of like three black people
to listen to your show yeah I'm trying
to think I think we have more than that
I bet we probably have about 5,000 but
all worth looking at the podcast I've
been noticing you say that like you're
talking about how so hard for white
people right now like it's like on one
hand you know I understand where you're
coming from I get all of minorities and
the LGP TQ w X Y Z's coming out of the
woodwork looking for troubles but on my
other hand I mean at least you guys
don't have to worry about like sitting
in your house playing Madden some drunk
off-duty cop comes in and shoots you in
the face or you get pulled over and
you're out there just trying to get them
hitters yeah and then you ended up
getting hit yeah that's tree trying to
grab a couple of burgers you had a
couple of black guys and it I bet it is
a lot more nerve-racking I was
about that imagine if black if black
drivers cars ran on nervous energy dude
that's the when is Elon Musk coming out
at that car for black drivers the car
that runs on nervous energy do cuz they
must feel it when you're driving around
I've thought about that all worked out
of police yeah I have to worry about
that so I get you feel like everybody's
coming down on you for being a white
straight male but try being black I'm
not saying go out and put on blackface
but just try it sometime I guarantee you
was not the same thing preach the peace
love and understanding for everybody and
I get where you coming from
but let's not take away from the fact
that stuff's out here's hard for us
color folks man pimping ain't easy livin
ain't easy breathing ain't easy but I
want you to breathe easy because I love
you you're out here doing the Lord's
work homie love you
Amen bruh love you man I appreciate you
calling in yeah you know what I can't
even imagine is something some things I
can't imagine you know about being black
I can't imagine grown I can't imagine
being like you said like they all like
if you're one of the only black people
in an area where it's a lot of white
people like cuz I gif I go into a place
that's a lot of black people I get
nervous you know I just get I don't get
and I guess I get nervous because some
of my experiences have been different
you know when I was growing up I had a
lot of friends that were black and then
also we get beat up by black kids you
know especially when you're poor doesn't
you know if you're white or black those
people like to [ __ ] fight and a lot
of there's a lot of ignorance at low
levels of poverty and and so there's a
lot of fighting man you know and it
would be crazy because I remember I'll
be doing Habitat for Humanity and
building houses for some of the black
families or whatever they did kids had
[ __ ] beat my ass you know and had to
you know just manage all the stuff
itself in my head because I didn't have
any you know my parents weren't I didn't
have an outlet emotionally with my
parents to talk about that kind of stuff
but I have thought about I've thought
about but and I'll never know what it's
like to go into a place especially if
it's a
right Aryan be a black guy yeah or how
nervous that would make me feel maybe
and I think it's probably different for
different people these days you know I
fine I have some black friends that are
a lot more chill or a lot more relaxed
or chill in certain environments and
some that aren't
and also it's probably the environment
too like if he took me into like a black
neighborhood that was more impoverished
then I would probably feel more nervous
than if he took me into like a wealthier
area wealthier black area you know like
at the Lenox Mall I was [ __ ] nervous
because I was like damn I'm the poorest
[ __ ] person in here and that and it
was all black people in there but yeah I
can't imagine what it's like and when
you're Dre
driving or something or you show up at a
place and people think you're gonna do
something just because you're black
I bet it's scary I've had two friends in
New Orleans in my lifetime two black
friends that have been murdered and by
out by other black men by are you're
black on black crime one guy they never
found my person or and I'm I say guy I
don't know if it was a guy who did it
but it's a day I can imagine it's been
dangerous I can't imagine it's been
dangerous man you know I want to be next
time I want to be Mexican I think and
then after that I would be black I think
black for me is still a little bit too
dangerous
but but I appreciate you help me make
think about that you know because what's
funny is when I was growing up in
Louisiana you don't see like you just
see like oh it you get this there's this
energy in here you don't see that you
don't see that bike you don't have the
opportunities you don't see that you
don't see it because you're also and I
guess I was a child you just don't see
that and this is also in the 80s and 90s
and now as I get older you're like oh
well yeah there weren't any black
doctors in my town because they they
didn't have the opportunities
but now I think I see a lot more stuff
in the world where there's more
opportunity for diversity you know even
on commercials
and I was thinking uh you know what's
funny is I thought about that I was like
man I you know I work hard to get to
Hollywood I work hard to get into an
environment where I can live out some of
my dreams you know Hollywood they're
always like oh we're so liberal you know
come here and chase you you know it's
like it's just that thing you can II you
can be anybody can be here and your
voice is welcome and yeah and I've just
a lot of times I've felt like because of
having a you know more of a rural accent
or being where I'm from and being white
recently more that I'm not welcome you
know where I got here in Hollywood it's
like oh yeah everybody's welcome but not
me because of the way I sound or because
the color musk because of the color of
my skin I would think that sometimes and
and you know what it made me think it
was like wow this is me it made me
realize this is what it must have been
like to be black in a lot of instances
you know to be sitting somewhere and
think man because of the color of my
skin or the way I sound over the phone
or the way I look my hair that I'm not
going to be welcome or I'm going to be
typecast a certain way
you know I could imagine this it's the
first time I was like oh wow this is my
this must be what it has been like for a
lot of black people over the years and
I'm not saying I have in a no but I
first second it gave me a perspective
switch for a moment like damn people
don't want me in auditions don't want me
in interviews think I'm you know you
know writing articles that make me seem
bad because they they don't know me
because they don't know that they don't
know my voice or my behavior this or
that or they just think oh he's he's
from Louisiana you know he is you know
he looks this way
he sounds that way he's that must be
what he is yeah man I can't imagine that
and then to still have to go to work
every day and had that in the back ear
head that that people aren't gonna give
you those opportunities it's wrong you
know and I think some of that comes from
a wrong time and I think that that kind
of stuff I hope is getting better in the
world and I believe that it is from what
I see when I go around I believe that it
is you know even when I look at all
you know just even advertisements on
television and you see now that like
you'll see like an I reference this a
lot but like an advertisement for
Disneyland or Disney World and you'll
see it be more of a diverse commercial
and that's good and here's why because
if a kid is sitting on his couch
somewhere no matter what color he is or
what his parents are and he looked at
the television he knew he's like oh I
can do oh that's for me too
you know when I think back to being a
preschool or something and thinking that
you know I'm sitting on a on a carpet
and I'm sitting next to a kid a black
kid and we're watching the same cartoons
and every time on the cart are the same
commercials and every time on the
commercial the toys and everything it's
always white kids playing with them man
wonder if that kid thinks inside of him
man ah I don't deserve those toys or I'm
not
I shouldn't have those yeah it's
heartbreaking you know it's
heartbreaking to think and Hollywood to
Hollywood's done Hollywood is you know
they that's another thing they try to
chant you know act like they've been
supported the whole time you know you
look at this guy Jeffrey what's-his-name
recently when they you know they took it
someone took a picture of the man at
Trader Joe's and and I think the person
that took a picture of him was just like
kind of shocked and then they wrote
newspaper articles that made it bigger
than it was you know the media blowing
it out of proportion but then I think
back like who owns the rights to that
way with his on-screen rights who owns
the rights to that man you know if you
want to sometimes I think about this and
I'm not comparing the two but when you
think of like modern-day slavery or
modern
a ownership you know that [ __ ] made me
sounds like how is it you know this
Mandy you're telling me that a guy who
everybody in America knows from he shows
and maybe the residuals from those shows
you just don't make so much overtime and
maybe because Bill Cosby went to jail
and those things went off the air but
man I saw that I was like who owns it
who owns the rights I bet you it's a
white person sitting somewhere in a
house in Hollywood that owns the UH that
owns the rights to this man's likeness
on television you know that [ __ ] him
over out of some bad contract 25 years
ago and that shell was like well where's
that where's the where is the social
media police on that somebody owns the
rights to that man to his likeness not
to him as a human you could see you
could see the power in him you know and
people knowing who he is and he has the
ball he has the [ __ ] the hoods but a
stand-in there and stacked vegetables
bruh and that's pride and this humility
and that is [ __ ] you know I'm guessing
he see I don't know if he's a father but
I hope he is because that's the kind of
man I would like to be my father you
know that's the kind of man I would've
liked to probably have taught me things
when I was young you can do this you
know you can be yourself you don't have
to look a certain way or you know no
matter what you do you can be yourself
you don't have to wear a mask you don't
have to not know who you are you can you
can [ __ ] stand there and look
somebody oh no matter who they are what
they're thinking of you and stack your
vegetables you know or do your work or
whatever it is you know clean that [ __ ]
or whatever it is you know but now I
appreciate you calling I appreciate you
making us think about this because
here's the thing the one of the biggest
issues I think in America's perspective
when I was young sometimes I would see
black people in my area you know just
seem like Oh a lot of them they are they
don't care they don't care about their
lives they don't you know they don't
you know they don't want they don't want
to work hard they don't want to do this
they don't want to do that and you would
see the kid and a lot of the kids a lot
of you know I've said before a lot of
the black kids in my area that by a
certain age they weren't even in school
after eighth grade I mean I would say
60% were out of school completely out of
school and when you're young you just
think you don't know it but here not you
when you're in that area at that time
not today at that time you be like oh
well they don't seem like they hate
school they don't care they don't want
to learn you know ignorant but then once
now I get older and I look and I'm able
to see like oh what these they're I know
what it's like to grow up in that
environment we're have the you know the
role model ship you know you don't have
the ability you don't have that some of
the opportunity you know you don't hate
even the role model ship is what's huge
if imagine being a kid you don't even
know anybody at a certain age that's
been to college how the [ __ ] you you
think you're gonna end up going you
don't know you don't think you're
allowed at Disney World you're not
giving in something to be an idea of
yours to go so yeah I mean it's
interesting man I'll and I like thinking
about this kind of stuff and I like the
fact that I'm open to have different
ideas about it and I like the fact that
you are too and I appreciate you for not
judging me solely based on one sentence
or on one thought but I think that uh
that look everybody has a different
experience and different you know an
experience in in Oregon will be
different than an experience in
Louisiana and that's another thing that
I think is is people's lives are
different you know somebody talking
about racism in in one city is gonna be
totally different than the racism in
another city and I also think that
there's too much you can't blame just
white there's a great deal of racist
people of all cultures and all
ethnicities black
Mexican I'm sure this hella racist in
Native Americans get on to some racist
black people I know some racist white
people but uh but as long as we act like
it's just a one person thing you know
we'll be in a tough so I think we're not
gonna get past it you know I think in
time we will get past everybody we're
also in this generation now where
everything is like you know we have what
we're new to these cameras and these
phones and he's a bill so it's frenetic
a lot of that's gonna disappear and will
it not disappear but it's gonna become
part of the main the main way we are and
so I think it'll calm down some but yeah
I don't not think that black people had
a tough time I don't not think that I
think in some areas probably tougher
than in some areas tougher than others I
think just my thoughts I might be
totally [ __ ] wrong probably him but
I'm not gonna be afraid to talk about it
and I don't think anybody should be
afraid to talk about something but yeah
if I had never gotten into a DIF I'd
never had the life path that I've had
different places different things seen
stuff I don't know if I ever would have
been able to see that as clearly and
been able to have you know be able to
see both sigh both perspectives in
different perspectives but it's
fascinating life's fascinating and we're
here and we're in we're in it we're in a
country that has a ton of opportunity
and I think that's beautiful and I think
I think but I think we is so we got to
find solution we have to move forward we
got to keep moving forward but I love
your attitude man I appreciate you
calling in all right let's take two more
calls man let's shut this thing down man
here we go hi my name is Jimmy I'm 21 in
California and huge fan even helped me
get to some [ __ ]
and that's kind of what I'm calling
about but I just wanna you know throw it
out there thanks for calling Jimmy
homeward in April I was in a motorcycle
accident they put my femur through my
Cydia Saturday
oh sorry Manas shook me down for a
second more yeah and I lost I lost a lot
of my my ground being there today I
would allow them firefighter before that
had happened and I was on my way to
start working edit at a higher position
I lost my girlfriend after the accident
I don't have been lonely since the
accident whilst you were in a motorcycle
accident and severely disabled
afterwards onward now I'm having no fun
like no money like my whole life just
kind of turned around after this you
know it's been hard to get back on my
feet my life still doesn't work properly
yet I don't know if I'll ever get back
on my feet the way I was before and his
I know I kind of like coming to an
identity crisis to this whole thing and
that's why I'm like you're picking on
this and I didn't I didn't uh been
drinking alone a lot lately I just don't
really know who to turn to at the moment
well appreciate you calling man thanks
for calling in yeah I'm sorry that
you're having to deal with this as I can
imagine that and that depression you
know I never had a handicap like that
you know I never had a physical handicap
but I've had emotional handicaps and I
know what it's like to stay indoors for
years and not want to do stuff and to
feel less than and you know to feel like
people don't want to like you're not
deserving of a good life and that stuff
builds on itself too you know
depression is like a moss you know you
in the dark it builds and endures it you
know in a wet indoors when you keep you
you know when you keep your body like
when you keep your life like a like the
bottom of a wishing well it gets you
know moldy and mossy and depressions
like that it'll grow on itself it's like
a you know like that that kudzu over
there in Atlanta Brandon over there in
Atlanta Brandon sorry but Brandon was
the previous caller
that's why I said that but uh but Yemen
who to turn to
I mean the truth is you got to turn to
yourself bro you know when people will
help you shoulder the load and you can
turn to friends you can turn a family
you know and that and those are tertiary
things are gonna help you I think but in
the end it's gonna have to be that turn
to yourself and you have to put a
timeline on that or anything and I'm and
look at and also I don't know I don't
know I never been in a motorcycle
accident I don't ride motorcycles
because of accidents that's why you know
I used to go speak about organ donation
because of my sister and the number one
organ donors are motorcyclists now do I
get jealous every time I'm in traffic
and see a motorcycle zip through yes do
I commend and do I do I respect the men
that can be out there and just get your
motor running and they got a hot piece I
ass on the back yes or even just a
little even if it's a puppy back there
still can be a beautiful little [ __ ]
little baby Doberman that looks like
it's down to [ __ ] you know but yes I
feel that yeah I'm jealous of that but
but yeah you got to turn to you bro you
got to turn to you you know what I um I
was listening to this podcast here they
called business and biceps it's out of
Maurice Clarett you guys were Maurice
Clarett from Ohio State University I
believe and and he they have it he has a
podcast now with John Bosco you guys got
it I was just listening when I was just
it's called business and biceps but this
is a clip from it that I pulled let me
find it here because I was hoping to be
able to use here here we go and we have
a generation where people just feel
sorry for themselves this is a Maurice
chord and I'm not saying that this is
you but I'm trying I'm gonna try to tie
these in a little bit if I can hold on
alright John thinks it's a store is more
important to Corey Sanatorium I think my
access for everybody got one bro
and don't nobody give a [ __ ] but you can
walk around thinking that your sad story
or the circumstance that you come from
is a valid reason it is a valid reason
to justify right you know why you're
feeling what you do are if somebody
should give you a break
nobody gives a [ __ ] bro you know saying
and and and like as hard as it is to
swallow for most people and as much as
we think that you know we should all
care I said you know nobody cares
besides your mother in the past on
Sunday he's getting paid to care and
that's from oh yeah the pocket is called
business advice S&S summaries Clarett
he's on their jump fuss they got a
couple of guys out there and they're
they're you know they're they're
Midwestern dudes and they're hard
hitters you know and um and Maurice is
talking about how nobody cares about
your sad story on here and and i you
know i don't know i don't i'm not saying
I disagree right I love his perspective
I respect his perspective I mean this is
a man who this is a man who want to talk
about the deck stacked against him in
the world I mean physically no I mean
when you look you you can't I don't
think you can talk about a you know a
black eye and say that physically they
have the deck stacked against them that
is dude I don't know every time I see
how a black you ever seen a black guy
you know with his shirt off you're like
damn that dude it's like he's just
living in a Lamborghini you know and you
show up with your white body it's a
little you know it can be a little I
mean at least my white body but this is
a man who's been through it all this a
man who's been through it all and turned
his life around Maurice Clarett and so
to hear him say that that you know
nobody gets listen one more time and we
have a generation where people just feel
sorry for themselves or John thinks his
sad story is more important to Corey
sanatorium I think my everybody got one
bro and don't nobody give a [ __ ] but you
can walk around thinking that your sad
story or the circumstance that you come
from is if
is a valid reason to justify right you
know why you're feeling what you do are
if somebody should give you a break and
so you know I this doesn't pertain
exactly to the motorcycle accident but
it's like yeah at some point we got to
look to ourselves we you got we have to
look to ourselves because in the end
it's really all you got you know you got
a mother that cares about you hopefully
and if you don't you got a father that
cares about you hopefully and if you
don't you have a brother a sister that
doesn't if you don't then you got me you
got the rest of this past weekend ders
you know you got I mean you have people
that will you can find people that will
be you we have to you got to meet the
world halfway we have to you know like I
didn't you know I was getting him drugs
and you know getting in a cocaine
problem and stuff like that and I didn't
get any better until I went to get
better you know I can't sit oh right you
can't sit around forever and think that
it's going to change the only thing the
only thing that makes change is change
that's it change doesn't just [ __ ]
happen it doesn't just happen there has
to be a catalyst and now you can sit and
wait forever for a catalyst if you want
you could wait for mother nature to pick
a lake up and bust it in the ice and
then make snow or you can get out there
and just put on some ice skates and
[ __ ] turn it on turn your whole world
in ice if you want you can get out there
but it's one of the you know it's like
the cat's it's gonna be a lot easier for
you to start that fire than a sit and
wait for [ __ ] fire to show up him out
but I Love You Man and I hope that um
you know I haven't never had that a
physical impairment and I can't imagine
what it's like but I hope that you feel
better and I wasn't trying to be mean or
anything but you know I don't want you
sitting here feeling bad and I don't
really know whether any other way to
inspire you from here or any other way
to be supported them by saying [ __ ]
get going and you sound like a nice
[ __ ] dude you sound like a good
person
and I think that the world needs you
brah cuz there's some shady [ __ ] out
there gang bruh let's take one more call
what up people Jordan from Mobile
Alabama what's up Jordan down there
mobile and that's uh that's that Alabama
god dang that Crimson Tide is good
aren't they
there's just they are good homework :
Lords never listen yeah one of seventeen
and a bully
the first and only child today fifteen I
got married then not long after that I
got paralyzed from the neck down from
getting caught up in a mosh pit
kind of messed things up for me I was up
in the hospital for six months
Jesus man I'm sorry to hear that brother
and dude shoutout to anybody that was
ever injured in mosh pits in the 90s I
can't dude Iram
do we you there be a band in town it
would be like electric puppy corpse and
you'd be like what you be like it would
be like uh dick down Falcons and they're
playing tonight at the [ __ ] crispy
crust hole and you go in and it would
all it would be would be a mosh pit it
was six or seven bad musicians and a if
one time I remember going to one
everybody played the drums
nobody even sang it was seven guys all
on drums three guys were on the same
drum set from different angles and it
was one guy screaming in the corner I
think something was actually wrong with
him I think his leg was trapped in
something and then it was uh it was some
guys and then it was just people mosh
pitting and mosh pitting it was back in
the day it would just be people fighting
in doors somewhere and it was kind of
sanctioned by music like the music was
the referee when the music would slow
down
that's when the the fighting would stop
and you'd pull the bloody people out and
whatever and put people's teeth back in
I'm we're putting somebody [ __ ] molar
in the back not even mine but it took I
remember one dude he would light his
hands on fire and it's come rolling
through the mosh pit by the end of the
night his [ __ ] who just have smoke
coming off the ends of his arms mosh
shout out to everybody who's been
injured and handicapped mentally and
physically from mosh pits in the 90s did
I salute you you know it was a it was an
insane time you'd be like come see ah
jaundice it'd be like jaundice pissed
toasters there playing a night at the
Holiday Inn but come see um come see uh
unseparated twins gasoline fire [ __ ] oh
they're playing uh uh you know at that
abandoned shed next to the Ramada and
you go in there no lights people beating
each other in the dark - drums and viola
and someone's screaming into a
microphone for help and that was that
was I think they called it mosh pitting
but shot out on word and I'm sorry you
got paralyzed from the waist down I'm
not trying to make this not about you
but I'm just trying to share that so
that was pretty rough I ended up getting
you know choking on medicines ended up
getting addicted to and it was pretty
rough and I know a lot of people take
home and deal with anxiety and
depression and I've dealt with that due
to this injury and I finally come
through it I'm off of all the medicines
I've learned to walk again Wow dude this
is awesome man and our producer think
this is a great call this is a great
call congratulations bro god I can't
even imagine not being able to move and
then they put you on painkillers that
are highly addictive you didn't stand a
chance man I don't think onward it
wasn't easy but I just want to get the
message out there that it is possible to
change your attitude and even with my
stars crazy think that you just you know
stick with it and keep moving because
that's what it's all about
you stay there and out ain't gonna get
better so mm-hmm
man this is crazy uh because uh you know
we might just stop after this because
this is um yeah man you know it's tough
look coming from you that's what I need
to hear
you know I've been dealing just some
little things myself here in there but
it's been making me feel just uncertain
and unsure you know and sometimes even
when things are going well there's
something inside of me that wants to
[ __ ] them all up but man you know how am
I gonna complain today when I know
you're dealing with this you can't even
move and now you can and now you're back
bruh
now you trick-or-treating again son
you trick-or-treat might use that coal
miner in the wheelchair and now you that
bug in now you're pregnant Selena bruh
now you about to deliver in this world
let's hear more why not just try to look
forward and do the best you can do and
yeah I really don't know what to say at
all time lucky man and keep it up man
when a guy who Kim who was handicapped
from the waist down and he's telling me
to keep it up
he's think he's calling to encourage me
wow thanks man I needed that dude I mean
how big is that that he you know that's
his situation he's thinking about moving
forward how do we move forward how do
you move for when you are paralyzed you
know when you are addicted this [ __ ]
guy that's one guy right there in
Alabama you know a place that's tough to
live I don't care what color you are or
what if you have a head or you don't
have arms or whatever you're in a
wheelchair you're electrocuted you
[ __ ] have wings poking out of your
back you're like Daniel you're a damn
hoof boy you know your daddy turned you
into a [ __ ] little deer you know it's
a tough look that's a tough tough tough
tough tough tough
of existence that this man has had and
he's moving forward bro I love it I love
it man
man I'm happy to be here to be a part of
this whatever paralyzes you bro if you
feeling down you know if you're
paralyzation has come from you know
decades of in generations and centuries
of your people being not given
opportunity you know if you're if you're
paralyzation comes from you know
self-doubt and depression you know
sexual inadequacy you know anger you
know issues where you felt like you
didn't get the love you needed as a
child whatever it is it's like look man
you heard [ __ ] Maurice [ __ ]
Clarett say it brah
and we have a generation where people
just feel sorry for themselves and
that's not we're not and we are we are
feeling sorry for ourselves and that's
okay we can feel it we can feel it we're
here feeling it that's what we're doing
and it's not all what we're doing we're
converse and we're figuring it out but
we can keep moving we can keep moving
forward there's a guy who's [ __ ]
paralyzed moving forward bro we can all
do it
so it's gonna be really awkward right
now to lead us out of here with this
scary music but you can always hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three thank you to
everybody that called
you know and if this podcast same for
you brother than and ain't for you if it
is for you it is for you I want to wish
everybody I uh I wanna wish everybody a
happy Halloween and I'm gonna wish
everybody and I want to wish myself more
patience with others and I want to wish
the same thing with for you and I want
to wish people that struggling with
something that they can start to
unstruck with it and feel power back
inside of themselves and
want to wish that for myself too and
that's okay and and I believe that we're
good people and I believe that if we're
not that we still can be and they say a
leopard a leopard never changes his
spots and I don't believe that I do not
believe that at all because I don't have
the same spots I used to have man I mean
I might have a whole new rash but it's
not the same spots let's listen to this
Halloween music and that's not good
enough
awkward waiting in the episode but
that's life boy sometimes it's good
sometimes it's weird sometimes it's
whatever as always you can hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three I want to thank you
to everyone that called
and I'm very grateful to have callers at
care enough to a share their lives and
be
[Music]
[ __ ] I don't know what B is yet and and
B share their thoughts
yeah share their lives and their
thoughts I'm grateful for that
[Music]
Halloween's coming bro what you want to
be who some time our now our would
settle for a little baby Ruth got ambra
a baby a ruth bruh
i don't know who baby ruth is ma'am but
i want to put that little bad girl in my
mouth you feel me again get see if this
is scary
[Music]
you guys be good to yourselves man you
probably deserve it
and thank you guys for being here with
me this week I'll see you guys on
Thursdays episode
[Music]
you